you'll hear the word tax bracket thrown
around a lot and there's often a
misunderstanding of what a tax bracket
is so that's what we're gonna do in this
video and I'm gonna do it in a very
general simple way that doesn't use the
exact same tax code of any particular
country but most countries use some type
of a progressive tax system that has
some type of tax brackets so let's say
my country has has a tax code that says
between zero dollars of income and ten
thousand dollars of income ten thousand
dollars of income you pay no taxes on it
and then between 10,000 and let's say
50,000 let me write that a little bit
neater between 10,000 and 50,000 so
that's 50,000 right over there you pay
20 percent of your income and then let's
just say this is very simple much
simpler than any actual tax codes out
there and let's say anything above
$50,000 anything above 50,000 dollars
you pay 30 percent 30 percent of your
income now the reason why I say that
there's confusion here as many people
feel that if their income throws them
into a bracket that they pay 20 percent
on all of their money but that's not the
way it works and let's just do a couple
of examples so let's say that someone
earns so let's say income income and
then let's think about what how much tax
is how much taxes they will pay so let's
say someone makes five thousand dollars
in income how much taxes would they pay
well the first ten thousand dollars you
pay no taxes so they pay zero dollars in
taxes let's say someone has $15,000
$15,000 in income how much taxes would
they pay will they pay zero percent on
the first $10,000 so would be zero
percent times $10,000 times 10,000
dollars and then the next five thousand
so they're they're going to be right
over here the next five thousand they're
going to pay 20 percent so plus 20
percent times
the next five thousand dollars the next
five thousand dollars so they'll pay
this is just zero the twenty percent of
five thousand dollars they will pay one
thousand dollars in taxes now the
misconception that many people have is
oh well fifteen thousand dollars puts me
into this middle bracket so I'm gonna
have to pay 20 percent on all 15
thousand dollars and that's not the way
it works you only pay 20% for the
increment that throws you in that
bracket so just off for the five
thousand dollars now let's do another
example let's say that someone makes
$100,000 let's say that someone makes
$100,000 $100,000 how much taxes would
they pay well it wouldn't be that
they're in this last bracket so they
paid 30 percent on their entire $100,000
they pay zero percent on the first ten
thousand zero percent times ten I'll
just write 10k for ten thousand then
they'll pay they'll pay 20 percent on
the next forty thousand this range right
over here so plus 20 percent times the
40 thousand and then they only pay 30
percent on the increment of their income
that is above this $50,000 threshold so
then they will pay they will pay 30
percent they will pay 30 percent times
the next fifty thousand dollars so ten
thousand plus 40 plus fifty that was
adds up to one hundred thousand dollars
times fifty thousand dollars so this
adds up to well this is nothing twenty
percent of forty thousand dollars is
going to be eight thousand eight
thousand dollars and then 30 percent 30
percent of fifty thousand dollars is
going to be fifteen thousand is going to
be fifteen thousand dollars so in this
situation the person will not pay thirty
percent on the entire hundred thousand
they will pay eight thousand plus
fifteen thousand dollars which is equal
to twenty three twenty three thousand
dollars in income taxes